um you talked about
obviously the capital deal came came
into play and a lot of people are trying
to sign you
um can you talk about like you said you
were eating dinner and someone called
you
yeah so i was eating dinner well
thanksgiving thanksgiving dinner so it
was just like three years ago this is
two years two years ago this is the two
2018. yeah so i had dropped this is when
i dropped a minute at a time and top
calls me and i'm he didn't he said oh
i'ma hit you but i didn't think he was
gonna hit me on thanksgiving
so i'm like who was this he's like this
is top i'm like what like you know what
i said it was top so
that that kind of like solidified what i
i was really really doing
at that time were you already did you
already make the decision to uh i was
already signing capital at the time
but i had already fulfilled my deal but
i still need to give him another project
because i want to put the project out
so long story short took the meeting
with top he was [ __ ] with what i was
doing but then i still had to fulfill
the rest of my duties to capital and i
you know i love top dog like i think
that's one of those labels that
represents artistic integrity what
you're doing for real
like yeah them dreamville i don't know
what they're going to do with uh pg lang
but
that might be a pocket but yeah i really
love what the guys over there at top dog
is doing
and like like i said i ended up staying
at capital you know fulfilling the rest
of my deal but
yeah i would love to work with top off
like he understands what i'm trying to
say